so see for me it's a bit like a magic  trick growing up I loved magic tricks  and but I really could only appreciate  them once I understood exactly how they  work that's when I could say oh this is  ingenious this is so elegant this is  beautiful  it's the same with nature I can  certainly appreciate the beauty of  nature and superficially you know  there's the places where I work and  especially in Africa they're majestic  but I really don't get a feeling that I  am part of that system that I fully  understand it and fully appreciate it  until I understand the rules that govern  its behavior the rules that organize  that particular system that's when it  reveals its mysteries to me  you